Eso significa 2555 picaduras infecciosas cada año.
Cuando estaba en la universidad, me mudé al valle del río Kilombero
en la parte sureste de Tanzania.
Históricamente esta es una de las zonas más palúdicas
en el mundo en ese momento.
La vida aquí fue difícil.
En sus etapas posteriores la malaria se manifiesta
con convulsiones extremas conocidas localmente como degedege.
Mataron a mujeres y hombres, adultos y niños,
sin piedad.
Mi institución de origen, Ifakara Health Institute,
comenzó en este valle en la década de 1950
para abordar las necesidades de salud prioritarias de las comunidades locales.
De hecho, el nombre Ifakara se refiere a un lugar donde vas a morir,
que es un reflejo de lo que la vida solía ser ahí
antes de la asistencia sanitaria pública organizada.
Cuando me mudé ahí,
mi función principal era estimar
cuánta transmisión de malaria ocurría en las aldeas
y qué mosquitos transmitían la enfermedad.
Y mi colega y yo fuimos
30 km al sur de la ciudad de Ifakara al otro lado del río.
Cada tarde fuimos a los pueblos con linternas y sifones.
Nos subimos los pantalones,
y esperamos a que los mosquitos vinieran a mordernos
para poderlos recoger
y verificar si portaban malaria.
(Risas)
Mi colega y yo seleccionamos un hogar,
y empezamos por dentro y por fuera, intercambiando posiciones cada media hora.
Y lo hicimos durante 12 horas todas las noches 24 noches seguidas.
Dormimos cuatro horas todas las mañanas
y trabajamos el resto del día,
clasificando mosquitos, identificándolos y cortándoles la cabeza
para poderlos analizar en el laboratorio
y verificar si portaban parásitos de la malaria
en sus partes bucales de sangre.
De esta forma no solo pudimos saber cuánta malaria había aquí
sino también qué mosquitos portaban esta malaria.
También pudimos saber
si la malaria estaba principalmente dentro o fuera de las casas.
Hoy aún capturo mosquitos para ganarme la vida.
Pero lo hago principalmente para mejorar la vida y el bienestar de las personas.
Este ha sido llamado por algunas personas el animal más peligroso del mundo:
y desafortunadamente es verdad
Pero, ¿qué sabemos realmente sobre los mosquitos?
Resulta que realmente sabemos muy poco.
Piensen que en este momento nuestra mejor práctica contra la malaria
son mosquiteros, mosquiteros tratados con insecticida.
Ahora sabemos que en toda África
tienes resistencia generalizada a los insecticidas.
Y estos son los mismos insecticidas,
la clase de piretroides, que se ponen en estas mosquiteras.
Ahora sabemos que estas mosquiteras lo protegen de las picaduras
pero solo mata mínimamente a los mosquitos.
Lo que significa es que hay que hacer más para poder llegar a cero.
Y eso es parte de nuestro deber.
En el Ifakara Health Institute
nos enfocamos mucho en la biología del mosquito,
e intentamos hacer esto para poder identificar nuevas oportunidades.
Un nuevo enfoque.
Nuevas formas de probar y obtener nuevas opciones
que poder usar junto con cosas como mosquiteros
para poder llegar a cero.
Y voy a compartir con Uds. algunos ejemplos
de las cosas que mis colegas y yo hacemos.
Por ejemplo.
Los mosquitos se reproducen en pequeños charcos de agua.
No todos son fáciles de encontrar,
se pueden dispersar por las aldeas,
pueden ser tan pequeños como huellas de caballos.
Pueden estar detrás de tu casa o lejos de tu casa.
Y, si se quieren controlar las larvas de mosquito,
en realidad puede ser bastante difícil.
Lo que mis colegas y yo hemos decidido hacer
es pensar qué pasaría si utilizamos mosquitos
para llevar los insecticidas desde un lugar de nuestra elección
a sus propios hábitats de cría
de modo que los huevos que ponen allí no sobrevivan.
Este es Dickson Lwetoijera.
Este es mi colega que dirige este espectáculo en Ifakara.
Y ha demostrado hábilmente que se pueden conseguir mosquitos
que lleguen al lugar donde normalmente vienen a buscar sangre
y que recojan una dosis de esterilizantes o insecticidas,
para llevarla de vuelta a su propio hábitat de cría
y matar a toda su progenie.
Y hemos demostrado que se puede hacer esto
y eliminar las poblaciones muy, muy rápidamente.
Esto es hermoso.
Esta es nuestra ciudad de mosquitos.
Es la granja de mosquitos más grande
disponible en el mundo para la investigación de la malaria.
Aquí tenemos colonias autosuficientes a gran escala de mosquitos de la malaria
que criamos en estas instalaciones.
Por supuesto, están libres de enfermedades.
Pero lo que estos sistemas nos permiten hacer
es introducir nuevas herramientas y probarlas de inmediato,
muy rápidamente, para ver
si podemos eliminar estas poblaciones o controlarlas de alguna manera.
Y mis colegas lo han demostrado que
poniendo dos o tres posiciones
donde los mosquitos pueden ir a recoger estas sustancias letales,
podemos eliminar estas colonias en solo tres meses.
Lo llamamos autodiseminacion.
Pero, ¿y si pudiéramos usar
el comportamiento sexual de los mosquitos
también para controlarlos?
Y, antes que nada, me gustaría decirles
que, en realidad los mosquitos se aparean en lo que llamamos pantanos.
Los mosquitos machos generalmente se congregan
en grupos alrededor del horizonte, generalmente después del atardecer.
Los machos van allí a bailar,
las hembras vuelan en ese baile
y seleccionan un mosquito macho,
por lo general, el macho más guapo en su opinión.
Se agrupan y caen al suelo.
Si observamos esto, es hermoso.
Es un fenómeno fantástico.
Aquí es donde nuestro trabajo de captura de mosquitos es realmente interesante.
Lo que hemos visto, cuando vamos a cazar pantanos en los pueblos,
es que estas ubicaciones pantanosas tienden a estar exactamente
en el mismo lugar todos los días, todas las semanas,
todos los meses, año tras año.
Comienzan exactamente a la misma hora de la tarde
y están exactamente en los mismos lugares.
¿Qué significa esto?
Significa que si podemos mapear todos estos lugares a través de las aldeas,
podríamos en realidad
eliminar estas poblaciones de un solo golpe.
Más o menos bombardeándolos o expulsándolos.
Y eso es lo que tratamos de hacer con hombres y mujeres jóvenes
por todos los pueblos.
Organizamos cuadrillas, les enseñamos cómo identificar los pantanos,
y pulverizarlos.
Mis colegas y yo creemos que tenemos una nueva ventana
para sacar mosquitos del valle
Y tal vez porque los mosquitos comen sangre, sangre humana,
es la razón por la cual son el animal más peligroso en la tierra.
Pero piénsenlo de esta manera:
los mosquitos realmente nos huelen.
Y ellos han desarrollado
increíbles órganos sensoriales.
Pueden oler desde tan lejos a veces a 100 m de distancia.
Y cuando se acercan,
incluso pueden ver la diferencia entre dos miembros de la familia.
Saben quién eres basado en lo que produces
de tu aliento, piel, sudor y olor corporal.
Lo que hemos hecho en Ifakara
es identificar qué hay en su piel, su cuerpo, su sudor o su aliento
que les gusta a estos mosquitos
Una vez que identificamos estas sustancias, creamos un brebaje,
un tipo de mezcla, una mezcla de sustancias sintéticas
que son una reminiscencia de lo que producimos en el cuerpo.
E hicimos una mezcla sintética
que atraía de tres a cinco veces más mosquitos que un ser humano.
¿Qué se puede hacer con esto?
Uno pone una trampa, atrae a muchos mosquitos y los matas, ¿no?
Y por supuesto, también se puede usarlo para la vigilancia.
En Ifakara
deseamos ampliar nuestro conocimiento sobre la biología del mosquito;
para controlar muchas otras enfermedades, incluida, por supuesto, la malaria,
y también aquellas otras enfermedades que los mosquitos transmiten
como el dengue, Chikungunya y el virus Zika.
Y esta es la razón por la cual mis colegas, por ejemplo,
hemos comprobado
que a algunos mosquitos les gusta morder en la región de la pierna.
Y hemos creado estas sandalias repelentes de mosquitos
que los turistas y lugareños pueden usar cuando vienen.
Y no te muerden,
esto ofrece protección durante todo el día
hasta el momento en que uno se va debajo de su mosquitera.
(Aplausos)
Mi relación de amor y odio con los mosquitos continúa.
(Risas)
Y va a ser un largo camino, lo preveo.
Pero eso está bien.
La OMS se ha fijado del 2030 el objetivo de eliminar el paludismo en 35 países.
La Unión Africana se ha fijado un objetivo
para el 2030 de eliminar la malaria del continente.
En Ifakara vamos con determinación a por estos objetivos.
Y hemos creado una cohorte de jóvenes científicos,
hombre y mujer,
quienes son defensores,